Godzilla king of the monsters is out and
as of this taping is rotten at 43%
coming in lower than both its
predecessors the 2014 Godzilla and 2017
Kong Skull Island they're both at
seventy five percent certified Fred
could this hinder the hype for the
forthcoming showdown in 2020 Godzilla
vs. Kong well it's time to talk hey
everyone I'm Mark Ellis and welcome to
the after show this is a spoiler heavy
discussion so if you've not seen the
movie yet you've been warned I am so
thrilled to have such a wonderful panel
here today joining us she is a host on
the YouTube channel geek bomb it's Maude
Garrett coming back yeah Mozilla
actually if you could sure I was I was
gonna go with Maude Ferrara I'll take it
yeah we got a mantra and joining us via
Skype is a rotten tomato certified
critic and she is also the host of
Beyond The Trailer Grace Randolph bag
with His grace here across the country
can you hear us okay I can't they're
coming from Boston so be warned and I'm
thrilled to be welcoming a very special
guest here in studio he is the
co-founder of giant robot giant robot
was once the premier Asian pop culture
magazine and since then it has become
the influencer of Asian pop culture
goods and services there's a lot of
galleries you'll find giant robe I that
you're all over the place and you're
here today mr. Eric Nakamura thank you
so much for joining us thanks for having
me man I am so excited to have you here
because I know you're a huge Godzilla
fan and you have kind of a story to
history with the legacy of Godzilla so
before we get into this decide this
before we get into this discussion of
Godzilla king of the monsters can you
give us a little bit of your background
with Godzilla and its fandom I grew up
with Godzilla I mean some of my earliest
memories are watching Godzilla movies in
Japanese so I've seen them all through
my life and I've written about it the
monster extensively and I've always said
that Godzilla is the beginning of Asian
pop culture it really was in a lot of
ways and so I imagine you were very
hyped for this movie definitely I mean
it's it's the that's the
this is the king and to prove that he is
the king of the monsters once again
there's a lot of monsters in this movie
I was over the moon about this I've said
this on camera this and Avengers endgame
were vying for like my most hyped of the
summer because I love this stuff so much
and what we're gonna talk about later on
in the show is the setup for another
movie that's coming out next year more
on that in a little bit right now I just
want to start by getting the panelists
take on whether this is a fresh or
rotten movie because like I said mom 43%
Rotten I myself consider this a fresh
movie because there it has its flaws and
most of this have to do with the human
component but I got what I came for with
this movie I'm going fresh how you
thinking ha good I agree with you that
you know you know what you're in for
with it I I think I have to go rotten ah
one I just think it was a bit of a
buffer flick where like leading up to
what we're really hoping for which is a
little bit more kong here but with this
one the monsters looked stunning
visually this was so epic but you know
the motive doesn't make sense like the
twist I felt was a bit of a letdown when
you had Vera Farmiga character just feel
like actually no even though my son died
in the last battle in San Francisco I
feel like we needed to kill a bunch more
people to make sense of the world and I
was like okay cool yeah I'm gonna check
out of that storyline so I'm yeah I
think that definitely is a huge
disservice to the film alright we got a
fresh we got a rotten grace how are you
looking at Godzilla king of the monsters
like two hour plus ride theme park ride
that's how I felt I mean the script
sometimes like it was like we've got 10
minutes till Godzilla explodes and I was
like let's get outta here
it's great so great alright so we got to
freshen one Rotten but Erik I feel like
your vote should count for two because
you're such a Godzilla fan please tell
me you're going fresh with this movie I
am not yeah
two stars out of five Rotten name it
it's just not there it tries really hard
it looks like the part it feels like
maybe it's gonna be the part
and it's not the part it's a rotten
couch it's a fresh chair and Skype is
fresh and let's get into this now
because I think that the thing that we
were most looking forward to anyway
going into the movie was the monster
battles the kaiju on kaiju action so I
was thrilled with so many of what I was
thrilled with so much of what we got to
see all the different monster fights in
the way they all played out I thought
the new look of Mothra was awesome I was
so thrilled to see Godzilla back I don't
know how Kong's gonna take him next year
I think he will I don't know how he's
gonna do it though so mod let's start
with you here what was your favorite
part of the monster vs. monster vs.
monster vs. monster brawling I think the
scale of it all I think that this
cinematography and the way that they
showcased the size and mass of these
monsters was done in such an incredible
way especially when you know that
Ghidorah brings in this thunderstorm so
a lot of the time is kind of silhouetted
like with like rolling thunderous clouds
that for me I was like ah this just
looks so great and then when you have
the human sort of running on the ground
and you see the scale of like a foot
landing down you're like okay this is a
lot happening here um I kind of wish we
saw more of their abilities like the
reason why I love x-men so much is
because everyone has their own unique
set of powers I wanted to explore that a
little bit more I know we've got good
auras lightning breath and we got the
atomic blast happening as well and
Rother is like healing energy abilities
that's kind of cool but I wanted to know
a little bit more about the monsters and
what they could do yeah Eric and I like
at the end when we get Godzilla he's
getting all red we get the atomic waves
going by did you enjoy the showcase of
special abilities that we got with this
I thought it was fun because for the
most part I mean the monster parts were
really fun in this movie and then the
less you know it's kind of like a mix of
a lot of Godzilla movies in the past all
in one but one thing about this Godzilla
that bothers me it's just not a handsome
Godzilla this is compare him to an angry
great deal Mike left grace do you feel
like we're body-shaming Godzilla here
too much I mean the guy's been
hibernating for the last five years
right boy well he's got a lot of mas
he's gonna be burning a lot of calories
in this movie because he's got I think
there's like a total of 17 monsters that
you're gonna get showcased in this film
at one point or another so grace did you
have a favorite besides our board
Godzilla that really stood out to you
that Mexico sequence was just stunning
when that guy had ejected into his mouth
I laughs yeah and the Rhoden versus the
military what was it was a pretty sweet
fight and like gray said wiping out
Mexico it was seeing Rodin I think if
you talk about the creature design Eric
I'm looking at Mothra and Rodan is kind
of the the new stars of this show where
we got to see I think it was paying nice
homage to their roots but also gave us a
little bit of an update well I think
it's really awesome to have I mean this
movie has the stars this is an all-star
team you know this is LeBron Kobe Jordan
Shaq all together right this is supposed
to be amazing and I still think even
with that kind of fanfare it still falls
short you know they're just not there so
I'm gonna give you some of the fights
that we got so we had Godzilla vs. good
deer right Ghidorah and then we had
Rodin versus the military like I said
and then we had Godzilla versus King
Ghidorah part 2 with the oxygen bomb and
then we had the final fight that was
Godzilla any of your Mothra then you
have your Ghidorah and then you have
Rodin what was your favorite brawl of
all the ones that we got to showcase I'm
talk Takei I really feel like that that
battle because you saw two Spurs two
different perspectives happening at the
same time those humans on the ground and
then Godzilla anger door and that was
like the first time that we actually saw
Godzilla in all his glory in a way but
everything else I was the same as Erik
I'm just gonna team up with him every
time we talk about it where I was like
it should have been great and you've got
a gliese of it and then you're like the
thing is like I don't know who any of
these kaiju are you know
like maybe you guys are such superfans
that you're like oh I want to see all
like you know but I'm like I get it you
know like kaiju you know I think I got
just enough and I really like that I
know like I think of any gun too much of
the mythology I've been like you know
they just
undaunted to know all this I think it
was like to me you know it was a good
introduction I didn't even know there
were that many in the movies quite
frankly yeah
arrogant do you think that they did a
good job of balancing the the fan
knowledge that somebody who's passionate
about Godzilla from decades past versus
the casual fan who's coming in who
doesn't know much about any of these
kaiju was that a fair balance deer or do
you think that they could have gone in a
different direction I think what they
did in this movie was take pieces and
small pieces from so many movies and
kind of like brought them in but they
don't really exploit them enough you
know it's just like a taste so a
hardcore fan like me will go hey that's
from this other movie but it sort of
didn't mean anything it was just like
throwing it in there but not you know it
didn't do anything and it didn't help
the story it didn't do much at all I
have a question Dora King Ghidorah is he
an alien I was like really
Haley ya the alien abilities was one of
the bigger curveballs there's a lot so
there's a lot of aliens in past Godzilla
movies you know like alien people like
humanoid aliens and this one doesn't
quite have that but then you know the
monsters I mean they're either
underground or they're alien and you
knew Dora yeah he was an
extraterrestrial all of a sudden I was
like alright cool there's a few twists
and turns that happen in the storyline
where you're like what alright I guess
I'll go along with this I didn't get
that feeling that they were trying to
cram a lot of the monster war into a
into a tight package with this movie
because again the monsters I think that
one of the things that people were
looking for this movie to do that they
didn't necessarily get with the 2014
godzilla is get more of the actual kaiju
on screen versus just having a lot of
humans running around with exposition
and dialogue that we didn't really care
about so that's our next topic is how
were the humans in this movie great so
I'll start with you do you think that
the humans let
some emotional weight to the storyline
or do you think it was more wasted
scenery when we could have just had more
monster fights I love them I've got the
twist with Millie Bobby Brown being evil
like her mom and the first like an end
of the first act this is really
different you know that's an evil kid
like that just like I was like that
really piqued my interest and made me
Billy okay this movie's cool and so and
I actually felt bad premiered for me at
the end even though she's trying to
destroy humanity I mean I mean that's
some acting if I can like squeeze out
some tears for a mass-murderer
I strongly disagree bow please I start
you're good I feel like the human side
of it was the weakest part for sure and
I'm kind of absolutely sick to death of
the villain trope of being the greater
good you know I like the fan owes the
fan eyes the Ultron the let's wipe
everything out and start again and we've
seen that time and time again and
initially I really liked it because
there were different shades of grey with
the villain and they really did think
that they were doing the right thing but
I think that it didn't actually really
work in this storyline it didn't make
sense Verint fermitas son was killed in
the 2014 movie I said I have that stance
on it was just like trying to connect a
square into a circle kind of deal it's
like this doesn't fit but I have to kind
of buy it and go along with it yeah Eric
I felt like that this movie started out
and I liked the connective tissue from
the San Francisco disaster when Godzilla
came there in 2014 and then I do feel
like even as a defender of the movie to
some extent that we started to lose our
way with a lot of the human storylines
and where we were going so I didn't buy
Vera Farmiga twist as much as some other
people did but it's one of those things
that I could get over that hurdle
because I want to get to the next
monster fight how did you feel about the
the humanity element in Godzilla king of
the monsters
I think definitely better than the 2014
movie because you don't want to overdo
the monsters but at the same time I feel
like the volume of the bad acting just
went up at the same time at the same
ratio so I thought the whole time I'm
watching bad acting on what it's really
just poor performances overacting story
better than this but I'm interested a
little better yeah C's wife that was the
most like a hot wrenching moment in
Godzilla and I guess I was waiting for
that again where I was like I know many
of those people just look at the faces
everyone's just like frowning the entire
movie I mean there's not just there's
just no balance whatsoever just seemed
like just very upset very stressed out
which I understand but at the same time
the balance is just so messed up in this
movie that it just I just lost it on
every scene just about well there's a
couple there's a couple actors that I
want to defend her I'm gonna say Ken
Watanabe because he gets stuck with
those iconic lines that are just they're
so hard to make believable and make
palatable both in the last one and in
this one so grace I think that that Ken
would be my human MVP but I'd also give
a special shout-out to Bradley Whitford
because I think that he's got a lot of
lines that could have fallen flat with
other actors and they actually did add
some some levity some know-how he's kind
of a jack-of-all-trades scientist I feel
like he actually lent her like when he
was on screen I wasn't upset I wasn't
looking at monsters drastic I thought
the head of the military the military
for monarch that actress did a fabulous
job I love the female representation in
the military you know the pilot I
thought that was great O'Shea Jackson
jr. you know he had some funny lines you
know it's like 2012
you know the roland emmerich disaster
movies you had you make a strong
impression as you can and the short
amount of time that you have and then
you know it's it's you're looking at the
spectacle and I felt very bad for Ken
Watanabe I feel bad for Vera Farmiga you
know and the fact that I cared about
these characters you know spent any time
with them I was surprised so you were
surprised by the twist with with Vera
halfway through the movie maybe should
be evil but we got me was that Millie
Bobbie Brown was in on it and she was
like dad you're not supposed to be here
like that was great okay Eric were you
were you surprised by the twist or where
he just bored with the humans by that
point he didn't care definitely Bart I
wasn't that surprised I was kind
oh god what are you doing you know like
this is just so typical so I wasn't
impressed at all but I do agree with Ken
Watanabe cuz I call I called him the og
you know he's sort of the one who's kind
of linking all the history of Godzilla
into this movie all the way to the end
and that scene went at the end like when
he has his Bruce Willis an Armageddon
moment yeah you can get a little I can
understand one getting emotional with
that scene he's it's like he's talking
to his he's really giant fire-breathing
dog yeah I feel like he's bringing his
yeah he's really you know he's bringing
the history right to the end that's kind
of how I saw it and what are those cool
he was the advocate for forming this
alliance between Godzilla and the humans
and he was the only one that was kind of
like championing that notion at the
start and I think he was an integral
part of the Godzilla story I just think
for me personally don't hire charles
dance if you're not going to use him as
the best villain out there Charles dance
was as this sort of like eco-terrorist I
think that I want to get to the
post-credits scene because we're gonna
get to that in a little bit but but that
post-credits scene if you had to give it
to somebody that is not named the giant
ape that I'm in love with I would say
Charles dance what happened I chased the
bathroom that was a long movie I was out
of it when the credits rolled second you
want to talk to me about that after
credits see maybe well we'll get to the
after credits scene but right now I want
to move to who this movie is for and
Erik I think that you'd be the resident
expert to go on this is that if you're
looking at Godzilla king of the monsters
is this movie for the die-hard Godzilla
fans or in a weird ironic way is this
movie may be off-putting to them but is
gonna be pleasing to the mass crowds
that are just showing up wanting to eat
a lot of popcorn and see a summer
blockbuster I think it's gonna do well
out there I think people are gonna watch
it but I think a fan like me we're just
gonna hate it and we're gonna make fun
of it and but that movie is there for us
to make fun of you know that's kind of
what it's about but for the casual fan
they're gonna love it seem odd I'm
reading a lot of like the the JJ Abrams
Star Trek reboot into this because I
from my friends who are hardcore
Trekkies they were not in love with that
movie or the way that it felt me I
didn't know anything about Star Trek I'm
the big star Wars fan so I
in there and I'm like this is great it
was great and it was a pop yeah popcorn
flick and that's you know I interviewed
Carl Chandler for this movie and I was
just like come on guys like let's talk
about this film and he's like it's a
popcorn flick like Godzilla's never
caught on in the West you know like
Godzilla's been this really popular
character for so long in in the East and
America I just couldn't care less you
know I think we respect them and we're
like oh yes Godzilla's cool but I think
that this is the first chance where you
got on the board where I think you know
the second bit of us we're still the
biggest audience in the world for now
and you know China is awfully close but
I mean like I think finally this is
what's gonna make American audiences be
like I can get behind Godzilla
yeah and grace I know you talk about
this a lot on beyond the trailer which
is the who is right in that if you have
a hardcore fanbase that you're trying to
please as a movie but then you also like
you're gonna move like World of Warcraft
where they were trying to please a giant
Warcraft fanbase but also open it up to
masses who just want to go see a movie
is there a happy medium that you can
possibly hit with a movie like this and
if so how close did Godzilla king of the
monsters get to it the box offices you
know Thursday night not as strong as a
Latin you know like that's not great I
think hopefully word-of-mouth will help
it
and I think it's benefits from the fact
there's no big movie like this for a
couple of weeks you know it has the IMAX
screens
although the IMAX is flipping over so
quickly now and this is a movie I think
that should be seen on IMAX so I think
this should be the movie that connects
and I think that fans anything that gets
your property to the next movie across
the line I think is helpful you know I
think tearing it down it's just gonna
hurt the franchise in the long run come
on is this gonna be a good gateway for
Godzilla enthusiasts who are who are now
forming we needed more calm I feel like
especially you get I feel like this was
the buffa movie the last one did well
calm did well they're both 75 percent
certified fresh' and then we have this
one as a stepping stone to get to the
battle that we're so desperate to see in
this movie to only understand and
acknowledge calm as like a blip on the
map on Skull Island
you know
and having like a little bit of video
footage of him raging out I was like I
need more than that not only am i Maude
Garrett fan because she's a big Tetris
enthusiast like myself but she's so good
at segues because that is our last topic
that would be Kong where was that where
was the Kong we got a lot of Skull
Island nods and so I was loving the
Skull Island that we got in this movie
Erik and then great little and then the
movie ends and we get the news reports
that these monsters may be drawn to
Skull Island and I'm like here we go
here comes a post-credits Tina I felt
myself getting atomic breath and then
the post-credits scene happens and it's
Charles dance buying a memorabilia I
mean I know it's cool but I'm expecting
to see like I'm expecting to for the
post-credits need to be on Skull Island
and Kong is like waking up 5:00 any
stretching he's doing push-ups he's
getting ready for the fight Eric did you
want to see Kong at the end of this
movie absolutely but I thought was this
a game of Thrones reference like he's
getting a dragon's head right what's
that what's going on here like it was
this like joke to that but I couldn't
quite I didn't understand what's going
on here like what was that for versus
calling right right and it's gonna it's
gonna help us continue the universe
grace I'm sure you read into that the
same way where it's like look regardless
what happens with Godzilla versus King
Kong which hits theaters I believe March
13th 2020 directed by Adam Wingard is
that we're going to have more adventures
in this universe provided the box office
holds up so if Charles dance is buying
some sort of maybe alien head off of
Ghidorah do you like where we're going
with that well they're definitely gonna
make converses Godzilla because they've
basically made it already and I was
talking to someone before this movie
came out and they weren't sure if they
were gonna see this film and I said well
you know Kong vs. Godzilla Snacks and
they were like oh well I'm definitely
saying that so I think that movie is
kind of like pre-sold anyway no matter
what but I agree I think they should
have mentioned Kong so much as they
weren't gonna show up and I probably
would have shown him in the third act I
wouldn't even put him in an end credits
sequence you know I just would have had
a third act not or at the very end of
the movie I'm here it's just how they
why they're why they're fighting yeah
why are they getting angry
and how is colin going to get to
Godzilla sighs because Godzilla it's so
huge now I feel like oh boy all right I
look I have made this defense time and
time again Godzilla is about 400 maybe
450 feet something like that King Kong
is actually shrunk kids yeah King Kong
used to be about 150 feet now it's down
to a hundred feet
however the athleticism that King Kong
possesses no other monster that we see
in Godzilla king of the monsters can't
get caught he can climb tree he can do
it spines firing up this is what we
needed Kong in this movie because this
is what we came most about okay look at
Grayson who's your piggy can't does King
Kong stand a chance against Godzilla
this is really like a rocky Balboa's
story Eric you're you're saying no
Godzilla Godzilla is gonna win this
thing going away easy easy it's not even
about the sighs I just think Godzilla is
just a hotter monster no matter what
Godzilla is the star King Kong yeah okay
but no this is a this is like a Jurassic
crazy weird beast you know if this is
the god this is the king King Kong has
Hazzard in name but King Kong's not the
king okay I hate to go back to the body
shaming we did at the beginning of this
vid but Godzilla looks like he's you
know in the best shape King Kong is
prime he's ready to go he's rested
unlike Godzilla I like King Kong's
chances in an upset but we have a lot of
monsters that we could be seeing in
Godzilla vs. King Kong so my prediction
for this movie I don't know that it's
all that spicy of it take is that
Godzilla and King Kong they're gonna
have their differences and then they're
gonna put their differences aside
because there's gonna be a bunch of
other monsters to come around so of the
other 16 or so monsters that may be
headed towards Skull Island
is there a monster that you want to see
join in that fracas model start with you
then Eric I'll start with you I don't
want to see that mammoth thing I don't
know how that's gonna get across the
water so no I don't want to see that
that's what I do know but I'm hoping to
see Godzilla's kid how about that
well we didn't I'm King Kong has a kid
too doesn't yeah
hey we could have a little kid fight and
then the grown-ups Oh
oh my gosh turn it actually looks like
it's Godzilla versus King Kong and you
realize it's only the babies and then
it's like reveals ah I love it the movie
that they're pitching grace is something
I think you and I would gladly show
about $15 to go see what additional
monster do you want to throw into the
mix with Godzilla vs. King Kong next
year I'm curious they're gonna pick
sides you know is it gonna be like a
rumble I'm just I'm sure that Dora will
come back yeah I think I think you're
gonna have a good door returned because
obviously Charles dance is negotiating
to purchase a head so I think we're
gonna see Kaduri again I'd also like to
see some sort of Mothra version come
back because I think monther might have
gotten a little shortchange in this
movie she got the new design she's the
queen
I want more Mothra in my life but the
final word is gonna go to our friend
Erik so Erik after all of this after all
this hubbub Godzilla king of the
monsters it didn't live up to what you
want so how many more times gonna go see
this movie I don't think I'm gonna make
it again I actually went back and looked
at some of the older ones and man
there's so much better so this one just
really stacks low you know this is just
really a maybea slightly it's
disappointing to me okay well neither
let me ask you because in Godzilla the
2014 version one of the big problems
fans had was the monster to human ratio
in the film I I defended it because I
liked that sort of you know that tantric
build-up to finally getting to see the
giant lizard on screen our fans going to
be satisfied in your mind with the
monster human ratio we get in this one I
look I think sir I'd think that at this
stage now that we've seen sort of
Godzilla and what what the kaiju you
know the pacific rims of the world we
know and expect big monstrous bull for
SH and I think that people are going to
go see Godzilla
because they'd want a popcorn flick I
just want to entertain and switch off
for a little bit and watch really cool
monster battles and there are enough of
them for this movie to be exciting for
them I also think that the kind of
person
Joseph's movie maybe kicked cants and
castles over when they were a kid you
know they like to stomp and destroy and
that's the point of it all of this but
for me yeah I'm actually glad that they
were more monsters over humans because
the humans was a letdown
yeah grace I think that you're gonna be
on the side of agreeing that the monster
human ratio is much better in this one
do you think that that's going to be
satisfying to the the worldwide
audiences yeah it was great I want to
see the humans come back I want I mean I
I would like to see these characters
stick around
whereas I thought the characters in the
last movie were just a complete joke and
a waste of space what about the cost of
Kong Skull Island integrating with the
cost of Godzilla are we gonna see Tom
Hiddleston and brie Larson maybe or even
Samuel Jackson have a chat with Vera
Farmiga I'm really proud that was the
70s
yeah you could you could do the opposite
of the MCU and you could just forward
age them and you could do so you could
do some clever makeup maybe John see
we're always like 150 year old having a
dog drinking a beer watch that would be
really cool because we've seen Samuel
Jackson D aged now we just make him
older well we're gonna have to wait
until March 13th 2020 is when Godzilla
versus King Kong I know this movie did
enough to sell my ticket to that film so
Eric you're not so high on Godzilla king
of the monsters but you are storied in
the legacy of Godzilla so what are some
of the better Godzilla films that you
can recommend to our viewers who maybe
haven't had a chance to check those out
yet I still think you got to go to the
original if you haven't seen any go see
the original one then go see something
like Godzilla vs. Mechagodzilla you know
and then go see something like Shing
Godzilla which is a 2016 and that's a
more modern version but all of those
Godzilla's look amazing my first
Godzilla was Godzilla 1985 fresher
rotten uh medium okay okay I'm giving
that fresh that we're gonna I got the
ruling from the judges we're calling it
fresh No
that is gonna do it for our show here
today in our discussion for a Godzilla
king of the monsters I want to thank my
incredible panel thank you to grace
randolph check out beyond the trailer
Maude Garrett check out geek bum and of
course thank you so much Eric and check
out giant robot for them I am mark Ellis
and you guys can check us out for the
next big movie that comes out we're
gonna be doing an after-show got a lot
of good ones coming up so make sure you
click that subscribe button to the
channel and click that bell it's gonna
give you an alert every time we have
another one of these drop leave your
comments below what did you think of
Godzilla king of the monsters who do you
agree with on the panel video light -
monster human ratio then you want more
Mothra and where the H was Kong let us
know all that know more we'll see you
guys real soon on the after-show
you